is there ways  in which mathematics can lead us astray  when we use it as a tool to understand  the physical world  yes i would say that mathematics can  lead us astray as much as  all physical ideas can lead us to  strength so  it is if you get stuck in some something  then you can easily fool yourself that  just like  uh the thought process we have to free  ourselves of that  sometimes math does that rule like say  oh this is such a beautiful math  i definitely want to use it somewhere  and so you just get carried away and you  just get maybe carried too far away so  that is certainly true but i wouldn't  say  it's more dangerous than all physical  ideas to me  new math ideas is as much potential to  lead us astray as all physical ideas  which could be  long-held principles of physics so i'm  just saying that we should keep an open  mind about the role the math plays not  to be antagonistic towards it  and not to over overwhelming it we  should just be open to possibilities  you